if you're breathing through your mouth
when you're sleeping what can happen is
because you're you're through the
neurology of sleep your central nervous
system innervates your muscles and your
tongue is a major muscle and so when
you're in rem sleep in particular your
tongue can become temporarily paralyzed
it sounds a little weird but if you're
breathing through your mouth and you're
laying back you can envision if your
tongue is not getting any sort of tonic
nervous system input it can collapse
your airway and this is very common way
more common than people realize like
sleep disorder breathing is a spectrum
people you have normal you know nasal
breathing then on the other end of the
spectrum you have uh sleep apnea most of
us are kind of in the middle where we
have these periodic apnic events one
clue of people who have this is they
wake up in the middle night to go pee
because when you're having this sort of
choking yourself on your own tongue
which is crazy a lot of people do this
um it affects vasopressin and the
retention of water it can cause you to
go peace